-My next guest is
a multi-platinum
recording artist and performer,
who has a brand-new E.P.
out right now called "Bang."
Here is one of our favorites,
Rita Ora.
Hey!
Oh, that's what
I'm talking about.
Hey, bud.
-Hi! How are you?
-I'm great.
Thank you so much
for doing the show.
I know that you're in Australia.
So it's probably -- What?
Is it tomorrow?
What day is it?
-It's tomorrow.
Yeah, yeah.
I have a black smoky eye for the
morning, just for you guys.
-Oh! I love the smoky eye.
Thank you, my friend.
I know you're in Australia
because you're doing the
Australian "Voice."
-Yeah.
-Who else do you judge with?
-Keith Urban, and then we have
Guy Sebastian, who we love, yes.
We love Keith.
And then we also have Jess.
It's an amazing mix of different
styles and different vibes.
And it's actually fantastic,
because working
with Keith and everyone,
it's really good to just,
like, turn the chair around.
And because I'm so obsessed,
you know, with Keith growing up,
loving his music so much,
I just throw
everything at Keith.
And I'm like this, "Hmm, Keith?"
-Can you see each other
in the chairs?
-Yeah, of course.
Of course, but with
my accent, obviously,
it's like "Keef"
instead of "Keith."
-K-E-E-F. Keef.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Keef.
-But it's amazing.
It's amazing working in
Australia, to been honest.
It's so beautiful, and it's a
blessing to be out here
and just be working
with everything going on.
So, yeah, I feel very lucky.
-Absolutely.
You know what
I was going to ask you?
Because you've obviously met
everybody in the business.
Is there anyone that you've ever
been just kind of like,
"Wow, that's -- Star-struck.
That's one of my idols.
That's like -- That's --
You can't even..."
-The highlight of my life
is obviously Madonna.
That's one of
the biggest idols of all time.
And I did --
-The coolest.
-Yeah. I had an
amazing moment with her.
Very awkward,
but also very unbelievable.
She really just made me
find my light.
And by doing that,
we had to kneel on the floor.
And I thought it was
"Like a Prayer"
in real life
that was happening to me.
I mean, I had to go
and breathe in the bathroom
before I actually did meet her.
I mean, this was earlier
in my career.
And I was doing a campaign for
her, a clothing line.
And, so, then she,
you know, came to meet me,
and I loved it
and I just couldn't breathe.
And then she was like,
"This is not my light.
Let's get down."
I thought, "What?
What's happening?"
And so we did.
I said, "Whatever she says,
we're going to do."
-I mean, well, she's Madonna.
She's the one and only, man.
-Yeah. The best.
-Well, speaking of the
one and only,
you are the one-and-only
Rita Ora.
I want to talk about your
new E.P., "Bang."
I love it. Here's the thing.
-Thank you.
-I obviously cannot speak
for dance music.
I'm not your audience.
But it's so catchy
that you can't stop moving.
-Thank you. Well, you know what?
You know,
it's so, so strange
creating in this time, you know?
And I think that's a lot
for a lot of people to handle
and try and figure out what
they want to do.
And so, for me, this is a
product of isolation,
and I mean that
in the most freeing way.
You know,
I wanted to do a project
that felt like
there was no pressure,
that a bunch of my mates really
can just jump on, get together.
We did it, actually,
all virtually, like this,
a bit like this interview.
Also, I actually collaborated
with an amazing producer,
Imanbek, who is from Kazakhstan,
doesn't speak a word of English.
So, I know
this might sound corny,
but, really,
music has no language,
'cause it was
proof with this E.P.
We really just connected
through music.
And I wanted it to feel like
a global phenomenon.
So, you know, I invited
David Guetta on board
and Gunna and Khea,
who is an amazing rapper
from Argentina.
So, really, there is
a little bit from everyone
from all over the world
on this project.
-You call it the
"musical science project,"
'cause I watched the short
you made, as well, online.
-Thanks.
-Where was that shot?
Because it was kind of --
It was beautiful.
-I really wanted to take people
on a virtual experience,
so we actually went to Bulgaria.
And it was freezing.
It was a four-day shoot.
And we really wanted to show
that contrast between
glamour and incredible fashion
and, I guess, cold, concrete
sort of architecture,
and that's something that
I'm really fascinated with,
'cause it shows
a sense of survival, you know?
I'm so, so honored that
everybody seems to have loved
this little world that
I've created.
It really -- I didn't have any
expectations for it.
So -- Oh, we also did a
special performance for you
at the Sydney Opera House
this evening.
-I mean,
that is above and beyond.
Thank you so much for doing --
The Sydney Opera House.
That's the best.
-I know.
I thought, "I have to do
the best for Jimmy."
-It's "Axel F", right,
you sample?
-Yes! Wow! Yes, it is.
I know, I know.
Listen, that reminds me
of my childhood.
And when I was thinking
and talking about it
with my production, I thought,
"Let's see what happens."
And then I heard it
and I thought,
"We're going to have to
just go for it."
It's just so --
such a famous melody,
and I was like,
"Let's just see what happens."
And I'm happy we did,
because the response
has been really good.
So it's good.
It's a good, good song.
It's fun.
-And it's a good timing,
it's perfect,
because Eddie Murphy is doing --
"Coming 2 America" is back,
the sequel.
So, I mean, "Beverly Hills Cop."
-It all makes sense.
-It's all making sense.
See? It's all really happening.
This is really happening.
-I think we're fortune-tellers.
I think we know the future.
-Yeah. You definitely do,
because you're tomorrow.
I'm yesterday.
-Oh, that's true!
I'm in tomorrowland.
-I love you, buddy. Rita Ora.
-I love you, too, buddy.
-Check out her new E.P., "Bang,"
which is available right now.
Rita is performing
for us after the break.
It is such a cool version.
You got to watch that.
Stick around.
Rita, come back
whenever, ever, ever.
-I love you so much. Thank you.
-Love you too, pal. Bye.